esta que tenemos aquí es la gráfica de
la función head es una función que
depende de ti definamos una nueva
función que llamaremos g mayúscula de x
esta función está definida como la
integral definida desde menos 3
x de la función g minúscula de t
dt y con esta definición de g mayúscula
veamos si podemos evaluar la encontremos
algunos valores de esta función
calculemos entonces g mayúscula evaluada
en 4 y también calculemos g mayúscula
evaluada en 8 te invito a que le pongas
pausa el vídeo e intentes encontrar
estos valores por tu cuenta antes de que
lo hagamos juntos bien empecemos con g
mayúscula de 4 esto va a ser igual
cuando x es igual a 4 este límite
superior va a ser igual a 4
así es que g mayúscula de 4 es igual a
la integral de menos 3
a 4 de la función g dt
dt y esto cuánto va a ser para esto
vamos a usar la gráfica tenemos kg de 4
es el integral desde 'the igual a menos
3 ubicamos de igual a menos 3 aquí
tenemos de igual a menos 3 y como límite
superior tenemos de igual a 4
no voy a remarcar con este con este
color naranja así es que estamos
integrando hasta t igual a 4 ahora
recordemos que esta integral nos va a
dar el área arriba del eje y abajo de la
función g de t
así es que va a ser esta área que
tenemos aquí que está arriba del eje y
abajo de la gráfica de gtt pero a eso no
le vamos a sumar esta área de aquí que
estoy sombreando en amarillo se la vamos
a restar pues si te fijas aquí la región
está al revés está debajo del eje y por
arriba de la gráfica dgt
tenemos que restar entonces esta área
así es que una manera de hacer esto es
separando la integral
así es que esto lo podemos escribir
déjame quitar esto de aquí para que
tengamos más espacio
así es que esto lo podemos escribir como
la integral voy a hacer esto en color
púrpura la integral desde que te es
igual a menos 3 hasta 0 de g de t de t
más y lo voy a hacer con amarillo la
integral desde que te es igual a 0 hasta
que te es igual a 4 deje de t dt y cuál
es el valor de estas integrales bien
para la primera aquí tenemos un
triángulo que tiene base 3 y altura 3
para calcular el área multiplicamos la
base por la altura 3 por 3 es igual a 9
es como si tuviéramos un rectángulo
dividido entre 2 así es que esto es
igual a 9 medios el valor de la prima
integral es 9 medios
4.5 ahora para la segunda integral
tenemos un triángulo que tiene base 4 y
cuya altura también es 4 esto es 4 por 4
es 16 este es el área del rectángulo
dividido entre 2 es igual a 8 pero
tenemos que restarlo porque la función
viene por abajo del eje t así es que hay
que restarle 8 el valor de esta integral
que es menos 8 de nueva cuenta estamos
restando el valor del área pues la
gráfica de la función se encuentra
totalmente por debajo del eje y así
obtenemos que quede 4 que es básicamente
esta área
- esta área es igual a 4.58 que esto va
a ser veamos
4 - 8 es menos 4.5 es menos 3.5 esto es
igual a menos 3.5 ya tenemos que de 4
ahora calculemos
de 8 y si no lo hiciste hacia el
principio ahora que ya viste cómo
calcular g de 4 ponle pausa al vídeo e
intenta calcular g de 8 por tu cuenta
una manera de hacer esto es aquí tenemos
esta área - esta área que ya hicimos
pero tenemos que calcular otras dos
áreas tenemos que calcular esta área de
aquí estaré aquí y estaré acá entonces
déjame rellenar las voy a rellenar las
regiones que corresponden para las
cuales tenemos que calcular su área
sería toda esta región que tenemos en
naranja y también tenemos que considerar
esta región que tenemos aquí entonces
cómo quedaría g de 8 quedaría la
integral deja de ponerlo con el color
correspondiente aquí sería este color
púrpura la integral desde que te vale
menos 3 hasta que te vale 0 dgt
dt más la integral correspondiente a
esta región ya previamente calculamos
una parte de ésta pero ésta va a ser
la integral desde que te vale 0 hasta
que te vale 6 de cdt dt y finalmente más
la integral desde que te vale 6 hasta
que te vale 8 de g de t de t
ahora ya sabemos que la primera integral
vale 4.5 vamos a evaluar esta segunda
integral aquí tenemos un triángulo cuya
base es 6 y cuya altura es 4 el área del
triángulo va a ser entonces 6 por 4 24
entre 2 12 esta integral tiene un valor
de 12 vamos a la siguiente pero atención
aquí se nos está olvidando que la región
está por debajo del eje y por arriba de
la gráfica la función así es que tiene
que tener un signo menos y ahora vamos a
calcular la siguiente integral la
siguiente integral va a ser el área de
este triángulo cuya base es 2 y cuya
altura es 4 esto va a ser 2 por 48 entre
esta tercera integral tiene un valor de
4 y esto cuánto es igual
veamos 4.54 8.5 menos 12 8.5 menos 12
vamos a ponerlo por aquí 8.5 menos 28
menos 12 es menos 4 más punto 5 esto es
igual a menos 3.5 menos 3.5 el mismo
resultado que obtuvimos anteriormente y
por qué porque es el mismo como es que
obtenemos el mismo resultado
veamos que sucedió cuando fuimos deje
mayúscula de 4g mayúscula de 8 restamos
el valor que se obtiene aquí estamos el
valor que se obtiene aquí y después
sumamos el valor que se obtiene aquí si
te fijas estos dos triángulos son
iguales estamos sumando y restando una
misma cantidad así es que la cantidad
original no se altera